it was announced recently ladies and  gentlemen that the population of Los  Angeles has officially reached 4 million  people  four million people 4 million people  yeah that's a pretty big deal that's a  big deal and I wanted to celebrate so  leizerman let's do this Jerry would you  do the honors please yes here we go  [Applause]  like God what what a shame is that a  baby  [Applause]  we were so close  it was twins just died no worries mate  this Capri has been milk recently unites  just unconscious oh now this fella here  he's got all his venom you know I really  wish we had a happy ending for this wait  a minute  Australia he's not from Los Angeles  [Applause]  you're right  [Applause]  you